and to go back to the first top gun i
mean was that very unusual
that idea of an actor actually flying
the plane themselves
and and and that footage had to be in
the film didn't it
yeah i mean for me i was like i wanted
to be in the movie they were you know
luckily
the studio they wanted me to do it so
badly that they i was allowed to
do that and then simpson brookheimer
were great you know i
learned a lot from them and tony was
that the first time you
sort of done that on on on camera yeah
when i did the f-14
i didn't want the pi you know the actors
to go through what i went through
because i trained with the blue angels i
flew with the blue angels and i you had
to do training to learn how to eject out
of the out of the aircraft
but i didn't know about jeez you know i
read about it you there wasn't youtube
back then
you know and uh so they took us up and
we started filming and we were hitting
some heavy g's and let me tell you it
was
jesus that's the kind of the pressure of
as you're going
right now you know we're one g it's our
body weight two g's is twice our body
weight and we're
in top gun i was pulling nine and a half
g's at one point so it's nine and a half
times my own body weight when we were
doing top gun and it was
uh not comfortable
but that that that nine and a half jeez
and
and he's piloting it so he's thinking
about stuff because i did one thing once
where i went to the european space
station
to do a feature uh for a television show
and he put me in that the spinner
yes uh and i got up to five yeah
and i was literally crying for me mum i
was like this is the worst thing because
your body just
collapses in on it you have to build up
too wow some people
sometimes can't ever build up to it i
mean i most of the airplanes and i fly
aerobatic helicopters and airplanes and
world war ii plane
but and you really have to take time to
build up to those g's getting in there
is quite intense
[Music]
you